what's going on guys this is rob and
before we start this video my fiance
mariah has a twitch.tv channel called
eat codes and you'll find it down in the
uh down in the description but she makes
like all kinds of food that's like geek
culture stuff video games and stuff like
that she recently bought a dc comics
cookbook and they're all dc comics
themed i chime in there every once in a
while and hang out with you guys it's
cool so make sure you guys go check her
out show her support
and uh yeah let's begin
alright guys we are picking back up
again with the three jokers and again if
you guys haven't bought this
you really need to right like this is
one of these stories that you
really need to buy and just sit at home
and read right like we're coming up on
the fall anyway so those of you guys who
live anywhere but like the southwest
you guys know as one it's getting around
that time of year where it's just a
great time
to like buy some comic books and just
read right like you guys know what i'm
talking about uh but it's
it's ridiculously amazing and at the end
of this i actually have a question for
you guys hopefully i'll remember to ask
it but what we end up doing here is we
pick up initially with the comedian
who basically arrives home now this is
kind of cool because the idea behind the
community and the way this kind of
played out here is we had
different iterations of the joker right
we had three versions of the joker we
had the criminal we had the clown and we
had the comedian
the clown was the one who shot barbara
gordon during the killing joke right
that's the way it seemed to kind of
point out or
seem to be the direction that they were
going in the comedian is the one that we
have here
and the uh and the the criminal is like
the classic joker and the way this goes
down
is you basically have this you know this
this comedian you know the comedian
basically
uh showing up at his home by showing up
showing up there to meet his wife
and to meet his kid this is kind of the
weird thing here because it almost kind
of points to the idea
that this is the guy who shot barbara
gordon right like this comedian is the
one who shot barbara
that the the clown was not the one who
killed barbara gordon it seems to be
kind of like jeff john sort of throwing
that out there right kind of introducing
that idea to us but you get this
scenario where you basically have a
meeting with his wife and basically
talking to their kid now the reason why
i say that is because those of you guys
who remember the story the killing joke
this woman looks a lot like his wife
right she looks a lot like the wife of
the joker before he became the joker in
the killing joke and she was pregnant so
it's kind of one of these things of like
what happens if she didn't die
right what happened if she wasn't killed
by the criminals joker still became
joker but like she wasn't killed by the
criminals and he just kind of went on
living his life as the joker with like a
family and all that kind of stuff well
it's pretty screwed up to be honest with
you
right like the little kid's like why
can't we just leave and she's like you
know
we can't he'll come after us he'll find
us that kind of a thing she's like you
need to come down to dinner you got to
play your part right you got to play the
role it's the only way for us to
basically survive this whole ordeal and
so what you end up getting
is this really really strange kind of
dinner right it's not it's not wildly
crazy like you know the new 52 death of
the family right where like they're
eating with their faces cut off or at
least they believe their faces are cut
off
it's just like a very tense and
terrifying situation because nobody
knows what goes on in the joker's head
right like the joker could just
arbitrarily kill you and it wouldn't
make sense to anybody but himself but at
the end of the day that's all he cares
about it makes sense to him and that's
all that really matters
the other part of this is that they're
having octopus for dinner and while the
kid doesn't really like octopus the
joker's like okay well let's see if we
can't turn that frown upside down right
what do you call octopus triplets that
look exactly alike a tentacle which is
kind of weird but the joker just cracks
up laughing and if i'm being honest with
you guys i think it's funny because of
the joker right
like here's okay here's a question i
want to ask you guys in the old batman
the animated series cartoon show
where you had mark hamill voicing the
joker how many of you guys would laugh
when the joker laughed because you just
couldn't help it that was me
i just couldn't help it it was just
funny
it was hilarious listening to him laugh
but we basically end up snapping back to
reality right
and you've got the criminal who
basically asked you know comedian who
were like who were you talking to
like like what are you what are you
doing here he's like i was having dinner
and he asked with whom and he says with
myself
and that's this it's kind of an
interesting thing because he's like well
you're basically wasting time
right like the problem that you have is
nobody else out there
matters except for batman right it was
your idea to let him in
on our little secret right to give him
give him a trail to follow to make it
more fun
and now one of us is dead right you
basically led the bat family to one of
us you know to to the clown and you got
him killed
and it's kind of nuts here because
looking at the first looking at the
first video that we did
the way this played out is jeff johns
kind of pointed at the idea
that the clown was the one who like
killed jason todd and the comedian was
the one who shot barbara gordon that was
kind of like the way this worked right
it was kind of him basically saying like
here are the jokers that you know and
it's kind of wild
because with this going down you
basically pick up with jim gordon and
you you kind of have like this apartment
that belongs to a judge
where the dogs are all like joker
infected right like which sounds
horrifying right like they look like
rottweilers or or like
pitbulls they look like rottweilers to
be honest but like they're infected by
joker toxin right so batman gets in
there batman knocks them out
but it's one of these things where you
basically end up finding out that this
guy
was at least it was believed that he was
mauled to death by his own dogs and in
some ways he was but he was also exposed
to the joker toxin and it's one of these
things where
it's it's a question that's kind of
being asked here why is judge walls the
person here right like why is judge wall
as a person who's dead
this doesn't really make any sense and
the response to batman is well you know
when
when jim gordon says like he retired
years ago the response to batman was he
didn't retire he was forced out right he
was a dirty judge
he was taking bribes from from like the
old arkham officials to send criminals
to arkham asylum right so
no big loss that this judge is gone
right he was a bad judge he was a dirty
judge the world's probably better off
without him
but it's one of these things where where
at the end of the day
barbara gordon basically walks in and
where jim gordon's like i thought you
were escorting one of the jokers the
response to barbara is i need to talk to
batman and when he asks like where's the
red hood she says you know it's it's
like well you know
commissioner gordon's like you guys are
looking for the red hood too and
batman's like the red hood's not a
criminal and that's when barbara says
yes he is and there's kind of this
unwritten communication here that's like
i need to talk to you right now right so
you basically end up having the two of
them take off batman the batmobile
barbara gordon on the on her little bat
cycle whatever it is and they kind of
have this thing where where juarez like
he killed
he killed the joker he killed one of
them like what are we gonna do about
this
and batman does not take the approach
that you think you would you think
batman would say okay then like let's
go grab jason todd like we're not gonna
kill him or anything but like we're
gonna take him like we're gonna take him
we're gonna take him to to you know to
some place where he can't escape from
right we'll finish the rest of this out
and then we'll basically go through and
then we'll deal with jason todd and find
out why he did what he did right but
like that joker's already dead
there's not much to be done saving
gotham is more important and while
batman does take that approach to a
degree he actually tries to rationalize
the actions of jason todd you know and
saying you know that when barbara
gordon's like now we have to deal with
two more jokers and the red hood because
we don't know where he is we can't find
him he's out there in gotham somewhere
and he doesn't
like red hood cannot be found if he does
not want to be found right like he knows
us he knows exactly what we would do and
how he would look for them and he knows
how to dodge us
but batman kind of responds and saying
like he killed a joker barber like
that's all we know right all we know is
that we killed a joker and there you
know that he killed a joke and there's
this kind of back and forth right that
where barbara gordon is just kind of
like no he shot a human being tied to a
chair like that's a problem the response
of of batman is you know the joker hurt
him right like he healed wrong
he got more violent you got stronger and
batman kind of tries to rationalize this
and basically saying like there's
something wrong with jason todd that's
why he did what he did almost kind of
making this argument it's not really
jason's fault that he did what he did
now he doesn't say it in so many words
but it kind of looks like that's more or
less an argument that he's creating and
batman kind of looks at that and says
like i've never forgiven myself for
leaving him in that grave right because
when jason todd died in the original
death of the family's
death in the family storyline when he
died in that he was for all intents and
purposes dead right
i mean that's kind of how it was batman
put him in the ground batman buried him
the fact that jason todd was actually
alive
did not become a thing until you got to
like under the red hood
slash infinite crisis and the big
question that barbara gordon had is that
if batman believes he should talk to
jason todd and understand him then it
turns into why are you doing it now
right jason todd's been back all this
time why are you just now at a point
where you believe he needs to be talked
to now here's the big issue that we have
with the three jokers right we don't
know when this story takes place and
that's really the big question that a
lot of you guys have
i'll tell you a lot of you guys asking
that in the previous video when does
this story take place because red hood
has his own story arc going on right now
that has nothing to do with this
when does this take place does it take
like do we is this a story that
basically takes place at the very
beginning of dc rebirth and if you want
to do a great big chronology you would
just put this at the very beginning of
the chronology right so
read it once you read dc universe
rebirth number one right i mean is that
what this is like we don't really know
where it fits in we don't know if it
takes place before doomsday clock after
doomsday clock we don't really know
we're not really given a definitive
answer here because it was a story that
looks like it was supposed to be written
years ago but the the whole point behind
this is that you basically end up
picking up with red hood now i
love the way that jeff johns writes red
hood and jeff johns is one of the few
writers that can write jason todd
incredibly well right he's one of the
few writers that can do that he
basically writes them in
in kind of the classic red hood fashion
and people who were fans of jason todd
right whether they got on board before
or whether like they're super old school
right so they've been reading since like
the 70s or they got on board with like
under the red hood and they've been
following him ever since but i have to
imagine
you guys love the way red hood's
depicted here right because it's classic
jason tot this guy like literally grabs
one of the joker's henchmen
and just snatches him up and it's like
you guys were basically told to find a
place to hide a whole lot of chemicals
so you better have a good response where
did you hide them where did you put them
and this guy is just kind of like i
can't say like i'm not going to tell you
because if i do the joker's going to do
worse than me right like he would do
worse so he would do worse than anything
you could do but he would kill me in the
worst possible way and the response of
jason is you don't have to tell me
detectors in the hood are already
picking it up right it's basically pool
cleaner now this is where you kind of
defect from classic red hood
if this was the under the red hood story
if it was like that version of the red
hood he would have killed this guy like
that he would have been like well now
i'm done with you pow and then like that
would have been the end of it right
instead he's like we're gonna hand you
over to the cops and this is kind of
cool
because jeff johns plays on this idea
that jason todd understands the severity
of what it meant to kill that joker and
he's trying not to fall down that
slippery slope
right which is one of those important
things when people kind of make the
argument well if batman killed a guy
then batman would become as bad as a
criminal
only if he allowed himself to be you can
stop
[Laughter]
the slippery slope argument is like
saying just because you sit down in a
casino table one time means you're never
gonna get up again and you're gonna turn
into a degenerate gambler that's not
true that's not true at all
basically saying people are not in
control of themselves right it's just
it's a really good way to absolve
yourself of responsibility right and so
with that being the case
it's one of these things where batman's
kind of like okay we'll try to find
jason todd but at the end
at the moment we can't we can't find him
right we tried tracking him we can't
locate him because he doesn't want to be
found and so he basically says we're
going to go someplace else and they end
up going to blackgate right now the
reason why they go to blackgate is
because of the fact that batman says
that there were fingerprints that were
found on the body of judge walls and
when barbara asked who do these
fingerprints belong to batman's response
is
joe chill right now as soon as he gets
into blackgate prison
actually one of the inmates here is
rupert thorne which is awesome to see
rupert thorne is old school he's
super old school he was part of the old
steve ingleheart batman run and i think
that's where he was introduced although
i'm not gonna swear to it but of course
you end up picking up with like the
cell of joe chill when batman gets in
there he kind of chokes up for a second
right he's like you know who uh
you know who i am right he kind of gets
caught up in the moment right like it
really shows that batman
is still afraid of joe chill it's it's a
very small
and a very nuanced thing it can be kind
of easy to miss but that's exactly what
it is
batman is still afraid of joe chill and
it's like damn right like he still
really is just a little kid crying over
the fact that his mommy and his daddy
got shot but as soon as he gets into the
cell
joe chill's gone and that's when barbara
shows up and says like they moved him
right like he's basically sick and you
end up finding out that he's in the
hospital wing and he's got weeks to live
because he's dying of stage four cancer
and so the question becomes if joe
chill's dying of cancer how did somebody
get their hands on his fingerprints and
how did they get
get those fingerprints to the body of
judge walls right now
that can be done in any variety of ways
right the joker could just sneak in here
pretending to be like a doctor hide his
hair right put like a mask over his face
or something like that like like what
what's his name did
in uh the dark knight right what um what
heath ledger did pretend to be a nurse
it was the ugliest damn nurse i ever saw
in my life but pretend to be a nurse
right and then basically walk in there
and steal the guy's fingerprints right
just put some tape on his fingerprints
and then
put on a crime scene somewhere it's not
hard to do nonetheless batman kind of
picks up on this
and and where barbara asked the question
like what's what's the connection right
between
the joker and joe chill and like
everything else besides you like what's
the connection there and so we ended up
finding out here is that jason todd
basically accessed
that computer from his helmet alfred
picked up on the location and basically
says hey like go find him over there
right so we end up basically picking up
and the gotham city athletic association
which is a condemned building so
obviously joker would operate out of it
and once red
once red hood gets up there he actually
pulls a crowbar out which is
cool once he gets into this place where
this pool is it's literally filled with
bodies
right like it is littered with bodies
and he sticks a tooth or i'm sorry a
q-tip down
in there and it starts to hiss right so
it looks like it's a pool filled with
joker toxin they're using people as
experiments to like use this toxin to
achieve a goal what that goal is we
don't know like presumably they're
trying to recreate the chemical that
made joker into who he was at ace
chemical presumably that formula's been
lost right over some measure of time or
they're just making more of it and so
initially like this body kind of flies
out
and it's just sort of like oh my god you
know like this person's infected joker
kicks him back into the water and that
guy is basically dead now but then he's
taken from behind by one of the jokers
right he's
snatched up you know and they're kind of
like we'd hoped you'd come and you get
this
amazing like probably the single best
moment in this whole story
jason todd basically wakes up tied to a
chair right and you have the criminal
who's there he's like you know jason
todd petty
thief you should have been cuffed and
arrested but then batman took you in
to make you the second robin you were
reborn and then after your death you
were reborn again right that's
that's the origin of jason todd summed
up in seven panels but he says like
things always happen in threes
you had a life you were killed you came
back to life and now you're gonna be
reborn again right you've been reborn
twice time to be reborn a third time
and it's one of these things where he
responds and he's like i killed one of
those jokers i'm gonna kill you too and
this person the joker just starts
laughing almost maniacally and then he
responds right it looks like it's a
painful experience he responds to jason
and he says i'll let you in on a secret
about the joker it hurts when i laugh
here's
here's the here's the thing all right
i'm gonna be honest with you guys here's
the thing i like the criminal
i like this version of the joker the way
that jeff john's write him dc comics
never use him again right like never
ever ever ever
ever ever ever bring him back or use him
again right like just
let him stay like this keep him like
this let this be the last time we ever
see him because if you do some other
writer is gonna get their hands on him
and they're gonna screw it up
do not do anything with the criminal
joker right so it's one of these things
where jason's kinda like so you're
telling me you're the real joker and
that's when he chimes in and he says who
is the joker really
and so it really seems to point at this
idea that the joker is not necessarily a
person the joker's an ideology and
that's something that really dc's been
pointing at for a number of years
through various stories right like scott
snyder's new 52 run
steve ingleheart you can even go all the
way back or you can go all the way back
during the era of like dennis o'neil and
neil adams right they're like the
joker's a concept he's an ideology the
joker represents
chaos and anybody can be the joker if
there's somebody who believes that chaos
needs to be supreme but for all intents
and purposes we as readers identify with
the joker as being a particular person
right like as being an individual who's
running around doing things but that's
what makes this interesting is because
what happens if you have three
individuals out there who all believe
that batman is bad
and like chaos should reign supreme all
they have to do is make themselves look
like a joker and then they are
right like that's really all it takes
and so they asked jason the question
they say why put on that helmet and call
yourself red hood
after what we did to you right because
red hood was the was the persona of the
joker before he became the joker right
in almost every single iteration of his
character he's been red hood before he
was the joker and of course you know
having having beat him to death the
response of jason todd is it's a joke
right it's a play on you
you killed me so i'm going to become not
necessarily you directly but i'm going
to become a mockery of what you stand
for and i'm going
you know my goal is to to basically
fight alongside batman right to use this
thing that you consider to be so
important
this this representation of chaos and
become that but become the opposite of
that to stand in line with batman
against you
and so it's one of these things where
they're like is it really a joke because
like we left you with brain damage and
permanent nerve pain
physical and emotional trauma so severe
that the only relief you
ever find is when you inflict pain on
others you and me boy we're more alike
than you'd care to admit
and that is true that's 100 true the
joker finds satisfaction with hurting
people that's the nature of the joker he
finds enjoyment in that now usually it's
part of some greater scheme but he finds
satisfaction
in inflicting harm on others
specifically if the harm that he can
inflict can affect batman and get batman
to chase after him again the joker finds
enjoyment out of that and so the
criminal kind of looks at jason and says
like you know that already right you
nearly died
and you blame the batman for it you hate
him for it and he says
i do too now this seems to point at the
origin the joker seemingly this idea
that all the origins of the joker are
the same in the sense that he
encountered batman under some strange
circumstance whether it's because he was
in the wrong place at the wrong time
what have you but he was knocked into a
vat of chemicals and that led to him
becoming who he was but he almost died
in that vat of chemicals that's the
joker's stance right so that's why red
hood and the joker are so similar it's
one of these things where
the joker kind of says you hate him most
of all right like you hate the batman
most of all because he's the reason why
you are where you are and he says batman
needs a better joker but simply put
you're not bright enough
you the way you are are not good enough
and so he says tell me jason does it
hurt when you laugh
and then you basically end up having him
cracked over the head with a crowbar
again now this is where things get kind
of murky here because
the comedian starts cracking jason todd
over the head
and then starts saying you know this
really is more fun than it was
the first time right so it looks like
this is the version of the joker that
killed jason todd jeff johns
seems like he could be going back and
forth now it could also be that i'm
remembering it wrong
right but it seems like he's kind of
going back and forth in between issue
number one and issue number two which
really kind of begs the question
what if these are just three different
versions of the same guy right like
three different personas or something
like that they're of seemingly the same
individual right so like there's
one joker there's the criminal element
to the joker there's the the clown
element of the joker and the comedian
element to the joker right so the
serious nature the goofy nature and the
one who just does things for the fun of
it and then what if something happened
and it just
manifested into three different versions
we're not really giving an answer here
right we're just kind of guessing at
this point in time
but we're back where we're seemingly
jason todd's being cracked over the head
he basically says you better make sure i
stay dead this time because if i don't
i'm gonna come back and i'm gonna kill
you and the joker's like no what are you
talking about i'm rooting for you i'm
hoping you rise back up and you prove us
wrong
i'm hoping you become the joker right
cue to barbara gordon busting the door
in alongside batman right and once they
get in there they're immediately
surrounded by like all these joker guys
right these these joker looking guys you
know and and initially like you know
it's kind of like they're they're not
really jokers they're just kind of
people who were taken in who are
basically you know
who were victims more or less but the
problem is that as they're attacking
batman
one of them hits his utility belt and
when that happens it basically ends up
calling in the batmobile which just
comes flying into that location and
actually kills a bunch of these guys
and so batman's like you know like we
can still save some of them you know we
can still save
jason and it's kind of like save me like
like what are you talking about like i'm
not jason and that's one of these things
where it looked like it was jason todd
who was uh who was turned but apparently
it wasn't right he's like i'm not i'm
not you know
but like i'm not jason right like you
know kind of barbara gordon freaking out
like jason is that you and he's like no
that's not jason and so jason todd is
not there right the pool's been drained
jason todd's not there and then
ultimately they of course
end up locating it now once they bring
him in jason todd has not really turned
he's not really the joker right he just
starts freaking out going off on batman
you know batman's like are you alright
he's like am i okay like what do you
think right like you did this to me this
is the second time i've been snatched up
by the joker and been beat to death at
least this time you made it in time
right like you made it before i died but
you put me on this path i'm in this life
because of you if it wasn't for you i
wouldn't be here right like i wouldn't
be
in this moment in this time living this
life that i'm living right now like he
just wholly blames batman it's resent at
his at his absolute
worst you know i hate you for this i
hate you for the fact that you just
buried me into the ground and then just
replaced me with robin's willy-nilly
without giving it a thought
right without even caring at all and so
barbara gordon steps up and barbara
gordon is like okay calm down we just
need to get you someplace safe now of
course they end up taking her to taking
him to barbara's apartment and then she
starts screaming at batman because
batman's like i've got to go do stuff
like check out gotham city because i'm
emotionally stunted i'm super stoic
which is not a practical lifestyle to
live and
uh and i just don't really reveal my
emotions to anybody because you know
reason and logic because that makes
perfect sense and so ultimately jason
todd of course wakes up realizing he's
in the the apartment of barbara gordon
he takes her book chronic pain
management right so we can kind of learn
how to how to cope with this whether his
chronic nerve pain that he experiences
and then once barbara gordon arrives
they kind of start having this
heart-to-heart conversation and the
response of barbara is there's something
that you have to understand jason
we all really thought you were dead
everyone thought you were dead nobody
knew that you were alive
if anybody had known you were alive we
would have come and found you we would
have moved heaven and earth we would
have burned down whatever chant whatever
town we had to get to
batman would have taken out whoever he
had to get to in order to find you
if we had known that you were alive we
would have been there by your side
grabbing you and bringing you back to a
place that's safe but it's one of these
things where he just hadn't quite really
picked up on that you know and it's one
of these things where she's like you
know we we care about you
we all wish we had been there for you
and he kind of responds and saying that
no one has ever said that to him and she
says she's saying it now and the two of
them
actually share a kiss now whether or not
this will turn into something i don't
really know and i'm a little
a little weird about seeing like jason
todd and barbara gordon kissing
it's a little strange to me because
they're not really brother and sister
but they're kind of like adopted kids to
a degree like adopted brothers and
sisters so like a surrogate brother or a
surrogate sister
sister and brother is involved in their
relationship in some way
and that's bad to like that's weird to
me to see them like
kissing it's like ugh it's kind of gross
but you know barbara gordon immediately
kind of puts it away he says it was only
a moment
no like that's that's not going to
happen you know friend zone like this
it's not going to happen right it's just
that's just not going to take place and
so you basically end up getting this
this kind of thing where batman
basically goes back right and he's
looking at like all this information
that he has at his disposal right
missing clowns missing criminals
different things like that basically the
joker files you know and kind of
skimming through this stuff and looking
at this as best he can
then suddenly something has something to
do with alaska right like he picks up on
something that has something to do with
this place right with this state that's
out there somewhere and so you basically
end up switching over to joe chill who's
been taken
by the comedian right taken by the
comedian version of the joker he's
basically snatched up and a video
camera's put on him and he says okay
like
lights camera action time to talk and he
says it's finally time to confess
mr chill why did you really kill thomas
and martha wayne because
apparently the reason that we got was
not the reason that it happened but with
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this video to an end if you are new here
to comments explain
make sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the rob corp if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like
and i will catch you all later
[Music]
peace
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
you